Yeah, thank you very much.
Hi everyone. My name is Gail.
I'm one of the founders of a company
called Native.
Um,
I'm I'm speaking together
today with Sajania, my former colleague
from AWS.
Um, so as mentioned, I used to work for AWS
up until a year and a half ago. Prior
to that, um, I was actually leading
a port called Security Hub.
During my time at AWS I learned
that
cloud providers AWS and
the other ones offer really
robust security capabilities
that customers can use
in order to make sure that their environment
is secure by design.
I've also learned
that.
While these capabilities are
strong and powerful, it's also
incredibly hard for customers to make
the most advantage out of those.
So in today's talk, we will talk
about why security by design is important,
about those AWS capabilities
that you can use to achieve security by design.
About the steps to
achieve that and define the guards that
you would like around your environment
and finally towards the end about
how what we do at Native
makes this simple, not just at AWS
but actually rather across cloud
providers.
With that note, I'm gonna pass it to
my friend and colleague Sajania
from the AWS identity team to
kick us off.
Perfect. Good morning. Hope you're all
having a wonderful
Thursday here at Reinvent.
All right, so let's start with talking about
a scenario that you are all probably
and painfully aware of, right?
Uh, which is your security team came
in and said, hey, we want to enforce
encryption on all of my
EBS volumes,
right? And uh your security
team did a scan and identified about
1000 unencrypted volumes,
right? And here begins what I
call a remediation treadmill,
right? So what happens? You reach
out to all of the resource owners, try
to find out who created them.
Why were there encrypted and
then go through the painstaking,
uh, process of encrypting
each of these volumes and then also
creating an exception list if you have a
legacy application that cannot
that forces you to re-keep the volume
unencrypted.
And then spend months together to
encrypt all of these 1000
volumes and then you celebrate
your success. Hey, you know, you're done with
meeting your security control
and then run another scan and discover
now you have 500 more after 6 months.
So it's a never ending cycle, right?
And that's the nature of detective
controls or a detective approach. It's always reactive.
You wait for things to happen and spend.
Expensive resources and
time identifying detecting
these uh gaps and remediating
it and what's furthermore concern
is your organization is at risk
while you're trying to detect and remediate
this. So how about we
flip this and move from
a detective approach to a preventative
approach. You put in a policy
saying that going forward,
no new EBS volumes
would remain unencrypted in your
organization, right? So this is the
premise of secure by design where
you are shifting from a reactive
approach to a preventative approach,
right? So this magically doesn't
remediate all the existing.
Uh, unencrypted volumes, you still have to
clean them up once,
but instead of all your, your security
team spending months of time
performing the same repetitive cleanup
job,
they spend a few hours enforcing
a preventative control and then
enforce and your security control
remains intact,
right? So a combination, this is the
whole foundation of secure
by design as I mentioned.
Right? And then you repeat
this process, not just for EBS, you
move it to EFS to S3
to KMS and all the other
AWS resources where you want to enforce
encryption by default,
right? So, this
secure by this approach is
not just applicable for configuration
of your AWS resources,
right? This is furthermore or much
beyond configuration.
Uh, it could be, uh, applied to cloud
footprint management.
Where do you want your AWS resources?
Uh, what regions do you want your
users accessing your AWS resources
in, right? So this prevents,
uh, shadow IT creation. Uh,
it could help you enforce your
data residency requirements,
right? Um, and then we also
can apply the same.
Philosophy to external access management.
Do you have partners?
Do you have secure third party integrations?
And you want to enforce your security
controls and requirements for each of
these external access patterns.
Similarly,
moving beyond the configuration,
uh, we at AWS have a
framework called data perimeters which we
will be discussing in a couple of slides.
So when you're enforcing your security
controls beyond configuration,
data perimeter comes into the picture.
And then you have privileged actions, right? You
want, you may have privileged actions like deletion
of databases,
uh, making sure that your security
services are not tampered with,
and you want to enforce and put preventative
controls for each of these,
uh, domains.
So by implementing secure by
design in each of these domain domains,
you're not just preventing.
And meeting one single
security control, you're creating a
secure architecture
across your domains.
Right? And
within AWS
we have certain native controls
that can help you
build on your secure design.
The first one is service control policies,
SCPs. I'm sure many of you are familiar
with this.
What you do with SCPs is you put in
control saying that, hey, for all my principles,
whether it be AWS services acting
on my behalf or my
own users, federated users, the
roles that my users assume,
they, I put in a boundary or the maximum
permissions that these principals
can access.
And then resource control policies,
RCPs work backwards. They come
in from a resources perspective,
so irrespective of who's accessing my
resources, whether they are my users,
whether they are external partner roles, or
any other service acting on my own
uh outside of my organization.
I want to control what how they
uh get access my resources and
what resources can be accessed so
that's where you're putting controls on your resources
which are called resource control policies
and then finally declarative policies we
talked about configuration management
declarative policies are.
Powerful because you can define
and then enforce the configuration
of your AWS resources and services
and we have additional policies
like VPC endpoint policies that control
what gets in and outside of your
network, resource based policies
and identity policies.
So using these,
uh, constructs,
for example of the scenario that
we talked about where we want to enforce
encryption,
we have a couple of policies.
You can always refer to these policies from her
GitHub, but the
the gist of these policies is
you're denying the creation
of EC2 volumes here,
the volume create volume call
if the encrypted con easy to encrypted
condition is false, so you're preventing
creation of any new volumes without encryption.
At the same time, you're also
preventing anybody from tampering
account level encryption setting, the default
setting. So similarly, you can
take the same pretext to EFS
where you are denying creation of file
systems or updating file systems if
the encrypted condition is false.
And then you can extend this for to
other AWS resources as well.
So the, the philosophy is the same. You're
trying to enforce the similar pattern
but for multiple resources.
Here's where the complexity increases as
you see the conditions, the
actions that you want to take care of
and control are different,
so you have to carefully craft each
of these policy types
for each of the AWS resources
and service types and need to know them.
And you have to design them such a way
that these do not block or interrupt
your existing business workflows at
the same time
implement your security controls.
So yes, this can be done, but
you need to understand and learn about
each of these services and the actions
that you need to control.
So we talked about data perimeters and
you, we have a whole,
uh, GitHub report where you can refer to the data parameters
so you do not have to start from scratch,
right? So in essence what you're doing
here is you are defining
perimeters.
So you're building a perimeter around your identity
saying that, hey.
Only trusted identities can access my
resources
and only trusted identities are
allowed from my networks, right?
Similarly for resources you're
saying my identities can only
access my resources or the trusted resources
that I know of and only from the
trusted networks
and from a network perspective
you're saying, hey, you know, I don't want anyone else
bringing in their
private credentials or personal credentials
and accessing from my network or through my
network. So all of these are
enforced through uh the policy types
that we talked about the RCPs, SEPs,
VPC, endpoint policies, and a plethora
of the conditions that we have.
The gist of this is this can be done,
but the complexity is that you have
to perfectly balance and create
a harmony
between the types of policies achieved that that
are shown here.
It, and that's where the complexity
of implementing secure
by design comes into place.
And this is only, we are talking about in
AWS
and but the
The complexity increases when it gets beyond
AWS and Gail,
do you want to talk about that?
Yeah, absolutely.
So thank you again for presenting this. I
couldn't have done it any better,
but
really to the point that we had.
Security by design is about enforcement.
It's about building an environment that's
always secure,
and the way to do that both in
AWS but also in other cloud
providers
is relying on the native
built-in
controls and security policies. That's why
our company is called Native.
As I mentioned, I used to work for AWS,
so I saw firsthand how
this is built
and baked.
We saw that the built-in native capabilities
can help customers enforce
things at the source, no matter whether
they go through
a pipeline or the console or for some
other mechanism.
It can help.
It does the enforcement with zero
latency. It's built for scale as
you add more and more and more accounts into your
organization. The policy would still be enforced
and would be enforced all over the place
and so on.
It gets to a level where
Amy Herzog, the CISO of AWS,
has said herself that the fastest
path to better security, to security
by design,
is using the protections that are built
into the environment.
And while this quote comes from the
CISO of AWS,
there are similar quotes on the internet
from the CISOs of all of the other
cloud providers.
But
I also know that making the most out of these built-in
mechanisms is complex.
So Janya herself showed you all of
the different condition keys and
policy types and so on,
and it, it's, it's a puzzle
that you need to go and build around.
It's, these are basically Lego bricks
and then this was just a WS
and now those things work differently
in Asia and GCP and so on. And
this is really where Native comes in.
So we've worked with countless
security architects, cloud security teams,
platform teams, and we've identified that
the process to
go and define those controls goes all
the way from discovery.
To planning the rollout to simulating
it all the way to
implementing them and operationalizing those
controls.
So you start with discovery, the effective policy,
what's currently at stake,
talking about security outcomes and translating
that you move to planning. What
do I actually want to enforce? How do I want to
enforce that? What's the rollout?
You then go on to the simulation. How
is this gonna impact my resources?
It goes on to implementation.
Just perimeter policies,
network perimeter policies on AWS
can be 30+ policy statements.
We go and do the translation for you, not
just into those two SEPs that Saljania
showed earlier,
but rather to
many more and different types of policies
and go all the way into giving you the implementation
instructions and the rollout and so on and so
forth. And finally
operationalizing what's the effect of the policy,
exception requests and so on and so
forth.
The point is that
this entire cycle that's made
simple for the platform
really allows you to go in and
ensure security by design.
It allows you, to my point from earlier on,
be secure the source itself,
build, operate environments that are secure
by design.
It allows you to unify your government,
your governance policies and your
governance processes
and manage policies across different cloud
providers from a single location.
So if you're AWS experts, but
you also have Asio and GCP,
you don't need to become experts in those clouds,
in those clouds. You can just take your existing policies,
hit a button, they would be enforced or
vice versa.
It gives you the end to end
operationalization capabilities,
what has been blocked by the policy, exceptions
management, drift, many more,
and it gives you adaptive coverage
cloud providers, I know this, I worked
for AWS,
they launch consistent
updates to.
The platform,
new APIs, new capabilities,
we go in and provide those updates as
things are being updated, as your cloud changes,
as your business needs evolve, we
allow you to
quickly adapt.
With that, I hope that was
a clear introduction into
why security by design is important,
why it is hard, but also how we can
be of help.
If you wanna learn more, feel free to just
stop by our booth. I'll be there. Ask any
questions. We will have
other fantastic members of the team there.
Feel free to
also log in online to our site at native.security.
Feel free to reach out to me on LinkedIn, Gal
Odo, to my colleague Sajania,
um, or to any
other colleague that I have that you'll meet at
our booth.
Thank you so much for the time.